None of us want a learning environment
where we feel threatened,
so for example,
I don't want to have to be learning in
an environment where there are people
with semi,
whatever you call them,
assault rifles around me,
right?
I don't want to be learning in an
environment where I have somebody who's
openly misogynistic and yelling,
misogynistic slurs at me all the time,
so all of us want safe spaces for
learning.
That's not unusual.
It's not a bad thing.
The question is where do we put the
borders on that and in some
circumstances in universities,
we've reached the point where we're so,
so dedicated to the idea of making sure
everybody feels absolutely comfortable
that we've shut down some people's
ability to speak and to think and to go
beyond where comfort zones may be and
that's where it becomes a real problem.
So it is not the case that universities
should be places where you feel
comfortable all the time.
Intellectually we're supposed to be
uncomfortable.
That's how we grow.
As one of my graduate school professors
said to me,
if you haven't changed your mind lately,
how do you know it's working?
And I thought that was a really good way
to think about it.
I was.
He said that to me when I was stuck in a
particular idea and I wasn't budging and
he thought I was being obstinate and I
was.
And I started thinking,
well,
maybe changing your mind isn't a bad
thing,
but what's happening on a lot of
university campuses has an ocean.
You come with your preexisting beliefs
about your identity,
about the world.
And no one's supposed to question that.
And I think that's very problematic.
You know,
for example,
people say,
well,
we don't want right wing people on
campus.
I knew I want everybody on campus.
I want everybody having the same
educational opportunities.
And I want the opportunity to actually
have real conversations about different
points of view.
Getting them out in the open,
airing,
them being able to have conversations,
arguments,
thinking about data,
thinking about evidence,
thinking about histories of justice.
It allows us to have those conversations
in a way that I think has integrity and
honesty and gets us somewhere.
So if people have the attitude,
you know,
some people are allowed on campus,
some people are not,
some people are allowed to speak,
that doesn't really get us forward and
certainly it is the case.
We should not allow people to openly
abuse each other verbally,
um,
in ways that are profound.
So for example,
using the n word for example,
but beyond that,
I think we have to have a lot of
generosity in terms of allowing people
to air ideas and giving everybody time
to do that so that we can have
meaningful education.
So there's over simplification of
history.
The sort of idea of everybody is good or
everybody is evil as opposed to there
are some people who are kind of nasty
but did some useful work.
There are some people are good but did
some terrible things.
Trying to inject some of that subtlety
and thinking historically thinking
empirically would be a heck of a lot
better than doing simplistic identity
politics where everybody gets devil
horns or an angel's halo and you account
for that based on current ideas of who.
What's a good identity and what's a bad
identity.
It's not a good way to think of.